well it's tax day the day that no one
celebrates I think that back actually
there are people that celebrate this day
it would be the CPAs and the enrolled
agents that do tax preparation because
as of tonight they are through and they
have just gone through a really
stressful tiring period those of you
there are endorsed local providers out
there in the tax prep business thank you
for what you do for taking on the task
of us not having to deal with all the
crap called filling out our taxes not
only is it unbelievably complicated not
only do most people screw it up but on
top of that it just pisses me off every
time I have to sign off on what we send
Washington so I was going over our tax
return with my wife a few weeks back we
filed Herzl a while back and paid it
today of course whatever was the
remaining that we owed today and she
only has two questions when she's
looking at our tax return not tax
returns as thick as a freaking phonebook
it's ridiculous she has two questions
what do we make how much did they take
that's all she wants to know and both of
those are possible causes for problems
what do we make how much did they take
then it's just devastating it's amazing
and so yeah this is national whining day
for those of us the 51% of us that
actually do pay taxes federal income
taxes are not paid by approximately half
the population about 48 49 percent in a
given year pay zero federal income tax
but the other half need to pay their
fair share I never understood that if
you pay nothing how do you gripe about
someone else paying their fair share I
don't get that it's not a conservative
or a liberal thing it's just a doesn't
make sense to me if you paid the same
percentage I make more than you maybe or
maybe you make more than me if you pay
the same percentage I pay it would be
different but you don't
I pay a high the highest possible
freakin percentage on there because I
make a lot of money and so I send a lot
of money which I really don't mind that
part of it but I do grow I do mind when
those of you that pay zero or pay less
of a percentage of your income than I do
say I'm not paying my fair share the
wealthy should pay more mark god I don't
know how much more we can pay really and
there's not that many of us if you add
us all up together it doesn't equal
anything so maybe everybody ought to pay
something would that be fair if you're
driving on the roads and the Army is
protecting you and the Navy is
protecting you and you're partaking of
federal services like I do I maybe you
ought to pay something I don't I mean
ten dollars what if everybody paid ten
dollars would that be fair but 50%
fifty-one percent of Americans pay all
the taxes but we don't pay our fair
share Thomas Sowell said it well he said
I've never understood why it is greed to
want to keep the money that you've
earned but it is not greed to want to
take someone else's money ever notice
people the screaming liberal screamers
in you need to pay more and you're too
greedy women you're walking my money it
was greedy who's greedy here I do not
understand that I don't grasp it at all
I mean I it just seemed to write
everybody out of chip into something and
I get the taxes are regressive meaning
that even after I pay the ridiculous sum
that I pay which is nightmarishly large
it's more money than I ever thought I
would make it my life was my tax bill
this year
so yes I'm whining but even after I do
all that I've still got a great life and
you know if you make twenty eight
thousand dollars a twenty three thousand
dollars in you're a single mom with two
kids and you know after you
even after not paying any taxes you
still you know it's still hard to buy
food it's still hard to buy
and so I don't want to punish you I get
the idea of a regressive tax system you
don't want a tax system because you cut
into someone's disposable income as well
all I want to cut into I don't want to
cut into their eating money or something
like that but then so I'm really
technically okay with some people not
paying anything because they're broke I
get it I've been broke I know how it
feels I mean six thousand dollars in one
year I didn't have a tax bill that year
I had other problems but I didn't have a
tax bill that year and so I get it I
know how it feels I was back in my 20s
when I went broke so I was happy to not
have a tax bill it helps me get back on
my feet and you know move on out of
there but I didn't gripe about somebody
else not paying enough taxes during
those years either because I kind of
figured I was gonna be paying taxes
again soon and I did so I really do kind
of think some of you ought to wake up
and go number one I'm not gonna whine
about what other people pay because
that's none of your business really and
it is greedy to want other people's
money in taxes are a form of
governmental theft if you think about it
you don't have a choice they put a gun
to your head and take your money I mean
what are you gonna do not go to jail I
mean these are your options right so it
is and considering I don't support
hardly anything on principle that that
money goes to I don't mind the military
and don't mind some of the roads and a
few other things but most of the social
programs and stuff that it's just there
there there have been proven to not work
so I don't like supporting stuff that's
proven to not work if it was a ministry
and it was ineffective like that I
wouldn't donate to it I donate to
ministries that are effective and that
managed the money that they have well
and they do a great service in the
community if the government was like
efficiently run or something
I'm sorry it's just about fell asleep
there in my dream but if it was like
efficiently run or something I guess we
wouldn't whine about so much but I do I
do resent buying $25,000 toilet seats I
resent that
or isn't buying $10,000 hammers and I
resent money going to stuff I don't
agree with that are on principle where
the government has taken social stands
on things I resent that I do and if you
don't like it you don't have listen the
show it's okay this is Dave Ramsey shows
was all about what Dave Ramsey thinks
that's why we call it the Dave Ramsey
show if you didn't know it's not about
what you think is about what I think and
you call in and you ask me what I think
and that's what you that's why people
listen the show like 15 million of them
so it's okay if this makes you mad and
like you're liberal crazy or something
just you want turn the tail just turn
the dial it's okay be all right you'll
be all right you let's get mad is it
don't go away don't go away mad just go
away
it's fine this is what we do here and I
have to spend at least one segment of
the show a year of whining about my tax
bill it's just part of my life and now
I've done it I got off my got out and
we'll take your calls now in the next
segment y'all ready triple 8 8 2 5 5 2 2
5 this is the Dave Ramsey show